well we've had the privilege of playing
with PlayStation VR for the past few
days and there are a lot of games coming
out at launch we've only been able to
scratch the surface thus far then we've
had access to like nine different games
thankfully a lot of those are really fun
Oh Jimmy I want to know which
PlayStation VR games are the best for
you and you think might actually sell
this system so the two best place you
should be our games for me one of them
is that is a game the other ones kind of
an experience and both are actually
bundled with in PlayStation VR worlds
which is like a forty-dollar compilation
package on the first one that I want to
talk about is called shark encounter and
they've actually show this off at
showing this off at like III and
different press event and things like
that this was my first time being able
to try it though and in shark encounter
they put you in a virtual shark cage and
takes place in first person as most vr
titles do and they lower you to like the
depths of the ocean and you're going
through and you see like coral and rocks
and things like that and all of a sudden
a giant great white shark sort of swims
around the cage and sort of checks you
out he's sort of confused as to you know
presence in charge figure you out
eventually he tries to pry open the cage
and and does so and then he kind of
swims laps around you a little bit more
and he kind of looks at you and he tries
to eat you and it is simply horrifying
and I'm not really into horror games but
VR does PR make scary experiences even
scarier in my opinion uh despite you
know being horrifying it was amazing to
me yeah and it's something that i would
put like my mom doesn't play video games
but it's something bad that i would put
my mom like under why not scare your mom
yeah why not like pretend scared my mom
to think that she's gonna eaten by shark
um so that to me it was an amazing
experience yeah just like creating I
just felt a really strong sense of
presence of being underwater no I'm also
a licensed scuba diver too and it even
fooled me
and the second game that I want to talk
about is the London heist and this has
you taken control of your basically your
character is a mobster mmm and you're
dealing with other shady gangsters and
things like that in it you're trying to
steal like a diamond and then you're
like in a shootout like in a getaway
vehicle on the freeway shooting another
you know mobsters are trying to get the
diamond so forth there were two
instances that really stuck out to me
the first instance was one of the
mobsters like points a gun right at your
head or rather my head and for me like
even though I knew I was sitting in the
office sitting in this room in the
office I just felt like a sense of like
to question this yeah like my virtual
hands came up to like block the bullet
yeah um even though that they never shot
at me it just felt wildly dangerous but
in a very cool way again and then the
other part of that that experience that
that really got to me was towards the
end of the game not to give awake too
much there's a part where you have to
choose who lives and who dies between
you know your mobster allies there was a
moment where I hesitated and I just like
kind of shot up into the air I kind of
wanted to see what would happen what
ended up happening was one of the
monsters was a guy a mobsters was like
I've had enough of this he takes out his
knife and he just stabbed me right in
the gut and kills me and it was the most
violent and visceral experience I've
ever felt in a video game before um but
again it was awesome so to me those were
like the little instances that show off
the true power of what VR can do yeah
and and that it's not just again
right yeah I I suppose like uh in in my
mind I am looking for the small wins
right and I found three games that
deliver this very dreamlike experience
of just being present but in an abstract
world right wasn't really like part of
action or an encounter with another
human uh I'll start with one which is
the most intense VR game I've ever
played called thumper this is a game
it's sort of like a rhythm game where
you know you're going down a track and
you have to hit a button in time with
certain elements on the track to the
beat but the thing is is that this is
incredibly fast and you're not really
playing a guitar like you're not filling
in an instrument as much as your sort of
participating in a call-and-response the
game will sort of echo a noise towards
you and you just have to repeat that but
what makes it so incredible is the space
is so rich with color and odd shapes
it's again very dreamlike an abstract
and it just grows you can say Peters
like an acid trip it well no that's like
but it no yeah it just it becomes more
intense and more intense and I've been
playing it for hours today actually and
it took me a long time to come down from
it for my pulse to go back to normal
because I felt so enraptured in the
experience now the game could be could
have a little bit more variety but at
the same time I'm also incredibly drawn
to it because it's one of those things
where I felt a direct connection and I
wasn't necessarily playing game in my
head so much as I was actually in this
space and participating in the moment
which sounds all hippy dippy but that's
kind of the way it felt and I got a
similar experience from res which i
think is maybe more approachable it's
not as intimidating an intense but
offers a similar thing you are flying
along this is a should add a remake of a
dreamcast game from I believe 2000 and
so you are started flying along and
there are little objects and you use the
head tracking to put a cursor on an
object and latch missiles on to it again
music is sort of the theme here so like
thumper you are trying to do things in
time with the music this game is less
intimidating it's certainly much more
peaceful so I think res is another great
example despite the fact that it's
almost two decades
it's still a really good game that
translates very well to VR is it a
straight port or did they like Taylor
certain things to so it's another's head
tracking it's basically a straight port
there is one level that I haven't played
yet we're still waiting for the full
version I've only played the demo levels
that came with the headset full version
has a level that is not unrealistic for
this experience but even so I think
right now if you put res in VR in front
of me or the Dreamcast original I would
immediately play the VR version because
just being enveloped and this is like
your eyes drawn right feels like you're
in Tron and and again another game that
falls into that category is super hyper
cute simple puzzle game on its face you
know those Japanese TV shows where
people are on a moving platform and
there are walls coming at them with like
holes cut out and they have to like bend
their bodies to fit through right so
what you're doing is you're using a
cluster of cubes and you have to rotate
it to pass through a hole in the wall
for every hole you go through more cubes
are added on this is again much more
approachable then maybe even res which
is super approachable but it does
provide that sense of immersion in what
really amounts to like laser light shows
from the 80s remember your school photo
so they would have liked that weird
laser streaking in the background it's
exactly like that and you're just
floating through it the whole time
trying to solve these puzzles which gets
pretty tough I think this game could be
it could take advantage of VR a little
bit better in terms of the gameplay it
doesn't really do so much it's much more
about the atmosphere but again I think
for people who just want to get their
feet wet and give it a shot which might
be the thing that really helps sell VR
rather than the intense experiences I
think super hyper cube is going to do
that for a lot of people
alright those are our favorite
PlayStation VR games that we think you
were going to like which ones are you
interested in let us know in the
comments below for more PlayStation VR
coverage stay tuned to gamespot com
I